[拍手]
皆さんは今何かに熱中できていることは
ありますか
これが自分のやりたいことだって
迷わず口にできることはありますか
私は今
尊敬できる大好きな先輩や後輩たちと一緒
に
毎日刺激的な環境の中でフルタイムとして
仕事をしながら同時にパラレルキャリアと
して自分で事業を立ち上げて会社を経営し
ています
こんな風に2足のわらじを履きながら毎日
楽しく走り回っているとよくみんなから
やりたいことがあってうらやましいなとか
私も何かに熱中したいけど何したらいいか
わかんないんだよねとかそもそもどこから
そんなエネルギー湧いてくるのって言わ
れることがよくあります
私も一時期自分のやりたいことが何か
わからなくてモヤモヤして苦しい時期が
ありました
でも考えても考えてもやりたいことは
見つかりませんでし
それは
やりたいことは探しても考えても見つから
ないからです
今日は私が今までの人生の中で見つけてき
たマジックオブトライングやってみるの
魔法について皆さんにお話しできればと
思います
私は幼い頃から生き物が大好きでした
図書館に行ってはちょうちょの図鑑を借り
て眺めて通学中には毎日キャベツの葉っぱ
の裏を見て卵を見つけて
道路にカマキリやトカゲがいたら連れて
帰るそんな生き物が大好きな子供でした
そんな私は高校生の頃人生を変えるほどの
大きなワクワクに出会いました
それはとある高校生物での授業での出来事
でし
た当時生物の先生だったあきこ先生は
私たちにその日
免疫学についていろんなことを教えてくれ
ました
自分を含む人間という生き物がいかにして
いきながらえ人はなぜ風邪をひきそして
それが治るのか
その話を聞いた瞬間私は何かに打たれた
ような衝撃を受けて同時に大きなワクワク
を感じました
それからあきこ先生は私たちに
免疫学を超えた生命科学という分野につい
てもいろんなことを教えてくれました
人の情報はagctというアミノ酸ででき
たDNAゲノムに書かれてるっていう
ことその情報を書き換える技術もすでに
できているということそれを聞いて私は
生命科学という分野にすごく興味を持って
大きな好奇心を持つともにロマンを感じ
ました
私がこの免疫学や生命科学に感じたなんで
かわからないけどめっちゃ面白いと思う
本能的に感じるこのワクワクの感情のこと
を私はスパークジョイと呼んでいます
私がこの高校の授業の時にスパーク女優を
感じたのはほんのきっかけにすぎません
でも私は運よくあきこ先生という
素晴らしい先生に出会えたことでこの
きっかけを好きに変えることができました
明子先生は
毎日毎日私が大量の質問を授業の最後に
持っていく私に対しても嫌な顔をせず全部
親身になって答えてくれるそんな素敵な
先生でした
私は先生でも答えられないような超変化球
的な質問を考えて持ってって先生に宿題を
持って帰らせるようなそんなめんどくさい
生徒でしたがそれでも先生はいつも
志賀さんの質問はいい質問ですね面白い
視点ですね私もわからなかったので勉強し
てきますと言って
毎回次の授業の時に
答えを持ってきてくれました
私の好奇心に真正面から向き合ってくれる
とっても素敵な先生でした
私は先生のおかげで
このスパーク醤油を感じたところ生命科学
に対してすごくこの分野が大好きになって
いました生命科学の虜になっていました
私はその後大好きな生命科学を続けていく
ことになり大学では乳がんの研究をして
大学院ではウイルス性の
血液癌である白血病の難病研究に道に進む
ことになりました
なぜ人は癌になるのかそのメカニズムを
解明していくこの生命科学的な視点から私
は毎日毎日
終電まで実験してそんな学生生活を送って
いました
そんな好きなことを続けていくうちにこの
生命科学は私のやりたいことになってい
ました
でもやりたいこと見つけるのって
難しいってよく言われますよねなんで私は
やりたいことに出会えたのでしょうか
私は高校生物の授業の時に生命科学やり
たいことに違いないと思って
授業を受けていたのでしょうか
違います
私が生物の授業で感じたスパークジョイは
きっかけでありそのきっかけを好きに変え
てくれた先生と出会いそしてそれが続いた
結果やりたいことになっていたのです
つまりやりたいことは見つけるのではなく
きっかけとその後の行動の結果なのです
ではこのやりたいことに出会うためには
一番最初のきっかけを見つければいいと
いうことになりますよねではどのようにし
たらこのきっかけに出会えるのでしょうか
2つ紹介したいと思いますまず1つ目は
変化が起こる環境に
身を置くこと
いろんな環境に身を置いてたくさんの
きっかけに出会いたいそう思ったらまずは
自分の身の回りのこと状況や環境を変えて
みることが一番効果的だと思います例えば
住む場所を変えてみるとかそれから普段
飲みに行かないような人と飲みに行って
みるとかもしくはいつも素敵だなと思う人
がいるコミュニティにちょっと自分も一歩
足を踏み入れてみるとかちょっとこれが
ハードルが高ければいつも言ってる
コンビニを変えてみるとかいつも顔お茶を
変えてみるとか本当にそんなことからでも
いいのですまずは変化になれることそう
することで
昨日よりも大きな変化に自分が身を置いて
いることに気づくと思いますそしてその
変化を楽しんでいる自分に気づくことが
できると思います
そして2つ目に
感情の変化を見逃さないこと
ワクワクすることから離れていると感情の
変化に気づきにくくなります今更わくわく
してもなーとかこの歳でいろんなこと挑戦
してみてもなとか
そんな感情が無意識的に第二の自分が現れ
てきてそんな感情をかき消してしまうこと
があります
小さな感情の変化に
耳を傾けてください
ワクワクの感情だけではなくて
モヤモヤするなとかネガティブなマイナス
な感情もきっかけに出会う大きなヒント
です
まずは感情の変化に
耳を傾けることこれがとても大切だと思い
ます
私はこの2つのおかげでたくさんの
きっかけに出会うことができています
それは大学院生の時に
没頭して熱中していた研究これが
実は自分のやりたいことじゃないんじゃ
ないかと目の前の患者さんを直接救えてい
ないんじゃないかとそんなモヤモヤした
感情を感じていました
自分の研究が論文止まりになってしまって
いてそれがちゃんと世の中に還元できてい
ないんじゃないかそういうモヤモヤを感じ
たのが最初のきっかけでしたそんな時実は
三学連携の先生がこんなことを教えてくれ
ました
研究や技術と世の中の間に大きな溝があっ
て
研究や技術を世の中に出していくためには
その溝の架け橋となる存在が必要なんだと
いうこと
それを聞いた時に私は人生で2回目の
大きなスパーク女優を感じました
もしかしたら今私が持っているこの
モヤモヤの気持ちが何か晴れるかもしれ
ないと思ってその先生がいる新しい環境に
身を置いてみることにしました
そこには
研究室とは全く違った新しい世界があり
ました
毎日新しい
挑戦をしている人たちがたくさんいて
世の中の課題に対して何かこういう解決策
はないかと作って修正してを繰り返して
いる人たちがたくさんいてそんな環境に私
が身を置くとたくさんのワクワクの感情と
それからたくさんのきっかけに出会うこと
ができました
そこでは私が自分一人だったら絶対に
触れることのなかっただろう
プログラミングに
触れてみることになってそこにいる仲間
たちと一緒にプログラミングを勉強して
みることになってそれをやっていくうちに
どんどん好きになっていって
続けていくうちに私は
ウェブサイトやアプリが1から設計できる
ようになっていて
自分が作りたいと思うものがある程度自分
で作れるようになっていました
気づけば私は世の中の課題に対して
技術を通じて
解決策を作るこのことがやりたいことに
なっていまし
たまた一つ私のやりたいことが見つかり
ました
では
きっかけの出会い方はわかりましたよねで
もきっかけ出会ってきたきっかけが全て
自動的にやりたいことにつながるかという
とそうではありません
では出会えたきっかけをどのようにすれば
やりたいことにつなげることができるの
でしょうか
ポイントはまずやってみるということです
変化が起こる環境に身を置いて少しでも
自分の感情の変化に気づいたらまずは何か
やってみる
例えば近くの本屋さんに行って関連する本
のエリアをウロウロしてみるとか
ネットで検索して関連するセミナーや
ワークショップに参加してみるとか
常に新しいことに挑戦しているそんな友達
にあってちょっと自分の話をしてみるとか
そうするとそこにいる人たちが
なんかこういうのやってみたらとか
こういう人いるからちょっと一緒に話聞い
てみようかとか
あなたの背中を少し押してくれるかもしれ
ません
そうしているうちにそのやってみるが次の
何か新しいやってみるを生んでいてそれが
また次のやってみるんで気づいたらそれは
あなたのやりたいことになってるかもしれ
ませんこれがやってみるの魔法です
やってみるの魔法が効かない場合もあり
ます少しお話しさせていただきますそれは
機能的思考で行動する場合ですどういう
ことか
コードには2パターンあると思います機能
的行動と演繹的構造です
急に難しい言葉が出てきましたね説明して
いきます
まず目標や目的が明確にあってそこから
逆算していって今の目の前の第一歩を
決めるという考え方を機能的行動と呼び
ます例えば受験に合格するというのが明確
な目標目的だとしてそこから逆算すると
合格するためにまず問題の正答率を上げる
そのために問題集を解くそのために
鉛筆を握るこのようにして目的が明確な
場合は今のこの目の前の一歩が明確である
場合が多いですそのためやってみるの魔法
が聞きにくくてどちらかというと今明確に
ある目の前の一歩をやるという方が
効率が良いということがあります
逆に目の前のことをやってみてそれを
積み重ねていくことで結果につながってい
たという考え方を
演繹的行動という風に言うことができます
まさに今回お話ししているやってみるの
魔法はこの演繹的コードのことを指してい
ます目の前のことはまずやってみる色々
やってみるとそのうちの一部が好きになっ
ているそのうちの一部が続いて結果として
やりたいことになっていた
これが
免疫的行動のことです
ただ目の前のこの一歩やってみるが
必ずやりたいことにつながるかどうか
わからないのでやってみるの母数を増やし
てみる必要があってさっきの機能的行動
よりも少し
非効率的に見えるかもしれませんですが
やりたいこととか目的が明確ではない場合
何がやりたいかわからないとなっている
場合にはまずは目の前のことをやってみる
という
演繹的行動も実は
むしろ
効率がいいんじゃないかというふうに思っ
ています
ちなみにやってみたけどやりたいことでは
なかったということも
ザラにあります
私はレジが好きでしたスーパーのレジうち
のレジですレジが大好きで小さい頃から
ホームセンターに行ってはよく両親に
業務用のレジを買ってくれとせがんで
毎年毎年サンタさんにラジオください」
ってお願いしたんですけど人生で1回も
レジが届いたことはありませんでした
でもどうしてもレジ打ちがしたくて大学生
になってようやく
練習時のバイトをすることができました
やってみたんですけどあんまり好きになれ
ず
そんなに続かず
結局レジューッチは私にやりたいことでは
なかったということが分かりましたこの
ようにやってみるを続けていって好きに
なれるかどうか
継続するかどうかでそれが自分のやりたい
ことかどうかは判断できるというのもやっ
てみると魔法の効果です
やってみたけどやりたいことではなかった
つまり逆に言うとやりたくないことが
見つかったということですねこれもやって
みるの魔法の効果です
このやってみるの魔法のおかげで私は今
とっても生きがいに感じることに出会えて
いますそれは自分の会社で
信頼できる仲間たちと一緒に開発している
ブランドエッグです
女性の社会進出が住み晩婚化晩産化が
どんどん進んでいく一方で女性の妊娠
リミットという生物学的な進化を進んでい
ません
いつかは子供が欲しいけど今は仕事を
頑張りたいそう思う女性が増えた結果今
日本では5.5組に一組が不妊治療で
苦しむそんな世の中になっています
出産や子育てが原因でやりたいことを
諦めるそんな世の中を作りたくないやり
たいこと諦めることのない世界を作りたい
そう思って私は事業を立ち上げました
私もこの悩みを持つ女性のうちの一人でし
た
私は大学院まで進学していたので会社に
入社したのが25歳の年でしたそこから3
年ぐらい経って仕事ができるようになって
きて楽しくなってきたタイミングで28歳
その時私は
海外勤務
海外駐在というキャリアを積んでいきたい
と思っていましたそこから1年後ぐらいに
行けたとして3年から5年の海外
アサイメントで日本に帰ってきて結婚出産
と考えると私は一体何歳になったら出産
できるんだろうすごく不安になりました
キャリアかライフかどちらかを選びどちら
かを諦めなければいけないそんなことに
不安や生きようと憤りを感じたことが
きっかけでし
たそこから私は何もアイデアがないまま
東京大学のファンドXというプログラムに
入ってその中で出会った人たちに
とりあえずなんか話してみたらと言って
産婦人科の先生を紹介してもらってその
先生に私まだ何も愛でもないんですけど
自分の思いを伝えてみてそしたら一つの
あるアイディアが思い浮かんでその
アイデアをいろんな人に話していくうちに
そのアイデアが好きになっていってそこ
から
経済産業省の指導というプログラムにこの
アイデアを磨き上げに持っていってそこ
からレッド関西というプログラムで
いろんな人に話をさせてもらってそしたら
35社もの
企業さんから
サポーターショーをいただくことができて
その後米国総領事館から領事監視を
いただくこともできました
大好きなアイデアが続けていくうちにやり
たいことになっていました
私たちは今女性の体に残された卵子の数を
計測する
血液検査キットを開発しています大好きな
生命科学の観点からこの大きな課題の解決
に挑戦しています
自分の乱視をすることで自分の卵子の数を
知ることで今を知って
自分と自分の大切な人とのこれからを
考えるきっかけを提供できると信じてい
ます
性別に関わらずやりたいことを実現できる
そんな世の中を作りたいこれが今の私の
やりたいことでありやってみるの魔法
データ生き甲斐なんだと思います
皆さんは今何かに熱中できることはあり
ますか
これが自分のやりたいことだと
迷わず口にできることはありますか
マジックオブトライングやってみるの魔法
今日からあなたは魔法使い
今皆さんが感じている小さな感情の変化が
きっかけですさあ今から何をしますか
ありがとうございました
[拍手]